how do you think that creators like
derek from more plates more dates or
greg ducette are someone who's changed
the way that the internet understands um
hormonal profiles and supplementation
because since watching a lot of
derrick's stuff since he's become big on
youtube i have been much more
considering the balance that's inside of
my body but i don't i don't think that
that was super common before guys like
him were around yeah i look derek's not
a scientist by training but he's done an
immense service to
the world because no one was talking
about this stuff it was talked about in
bodybuilding circles
where they talk very openly
it was
starting to emerge in
testosterone replacement therapy clinics
and then mostly guys were doing this
stuff and lying about it right they're
doing it but then they don't want to
talk about actually
kudos to joe rogan who years ago came
out and said yeah he decided to start
doing trt and low dose of testosterone
he's already successfully reproduced and
so he you know he brought it up and and
you know
it's clear that this is becoming more
common
here are some of the general principles
that i think forgive me derek if i get
this wrong in terms of what you believe
because i never want to speak for
anybody else but my read of the science
and the actual protocols
speak to the idea that
many people do not need testosterone
replacement
young guys should really avoid doing
anabolic steroids it can really mess up
their system not just physically not
just for the ability to have kids later
but
lead to all sorts of sexual issues and
sexual performance issues like there
needs to be some medical incentive right
hypogonadism for instance
but
at the point where someone either has
bank sperm or decides they don't want
any more kids or is willing to do
something like take hcg to maintain
testicular and uh function and
spermatogenesis it's very clear that
going with the lowest you know doctor
described right i'm not talking about
illicit use that the lowest possible
dosage of testosterone therapy is going
to be better than for instance taking
200 milligrams in a one mil injection
every two weeks right because you get
these huge increases and then these
troughs so people say something that
you've learned from derek yes and in
talking with other people and i i'm no
longer doing this um but i i did a run
of it from 45 to 46 years old and
nothing before that um and i did it
because i'm working on a on a book
really that has a whole section on
hormone therapies i wanted to see what
it was like i'll tell you basically
testosterone gives you more energy to
work more
um if it's done appropriately right
maybe that's the the secret for lex
maybe maybe
it's just brimming maze brimming and
i'll say when i went into it my levels
were mid-range they were fine high to
mid-range they were kind of like sevens
eights but i was doing some
supplementation to support that i've
since gone back to that it was funny
when you say something on the internet
people think that means it's forever
right it is possible to start and come
off right so so what i've done and so
here's what's what's relevant here
people are now
spacing out you know 30 milligrams on
monday 30 milligrams on wednesday 30
milligrams on fridays like i have a low
reasonable dose again talk to your
doctor these aren't recommended dosages
that's more typical another thing that's
really important is that people have
traditionally blocked estrogen by
increases
while doing this by taking an aromatase
inhibitor novodax arimidex these kinds
of things
that
almost often is a bad idea almost often
because
having enough estrogen around allows you
to maintain
cognitive function
and libido a lot of guys think it's just
you know and it is true if estrogen is
very high and testosterone is very low
libido can suffer but if testosterone is
very high and estrogen is very low
libido can really suffer so a lot of
people who are crushing their estrogen
realize that by coming off some of those
drugs they feel far better
far more interesting far better so most
people i know that are doing this are
taking low doses of testosterone
semi-frequently throughout the week
20 to 30 milligrams every other day or
so there's a lot of variation around
this and then
not doing anything to reduce aromatase
or if they are taking very low doses not
one milligram of arimidex but maybe
something like 0.1 milligrams of
arimidex every third day or so again not
a recommendation talk to your doctor
the smarter clinics are starting to
think about this and actually i don't
have any financial relationship to derek
or to merrick health which is his clinic
but from what i understand they do a
very good job i did help them design a
herbal
mostly herbal supplement for
testosterone support for people who are
not on trt as things like tonga ali
fedoja but unbeknownst to most people i
i've not made one penny on that that was
just based on a conversation of the
research with him and dr kyle gillette
and a few other people so
estrogen can help maintain libido also
can increase libido now here's something
i learned that's really interesting from
peter attila recently
women as we know make both testosterone
and estrogen and of course a bunch of
other hormones too
if they get their blood work back and
you were to adjust the
units that those hormones are measured
in nanograms per deciliter in some cases
picograms per deciliter in other cases
if you normalize them all to the same
nanograms per deciliter you would find
that a healthy woman has more
testosterone than she does estrogen
that's right
i asked him this three times you're
telling me that women have more
testosterone circulating in them than
estrogen he said absolutely now this
maybe there's a there's a caveat to that
during some phase of the menstrual cycle
but
that does not mean that their
testosterone levels are higher than that
of men but this is remarkable right this
means that these androgens testosterone
and
are doing interesting things in men
and in women and estrogen as we just
described are doing really interesting
things certainly in women and in men so
this idea of more testosterone less
estrogen good is always the case that's
simply false you have to think about
whether or not a man whether that's a
woman whether or not
the goal is more or less typically
people aren't going for less libido but
i suppose it's possible some people out
there with them some people might be
highly distracted by an excessive libido
right that's a different story but and
then of course dht so i think one of the
things that derek has really contributed
to the world and i think is important
for people know that a lot of the drugs
that are used to treat hair loss
finasteride propecia things like that
block dht receptors dihydrotestosterone
dhc is responsible for beard growth in
the face and for balding male pattern
baldness people because they want their
hair we'll take these drugs if they take
it in pill form they're blocking dht
everywhere and they can experience
severe defects in libido and sexual
performance now before that choice
between your hair and your erection for
a lot of people it is right i mean for
now there are now topical things and
derek talks about all this kind of thing
they're talking really really deep he
goes really deep into all this and
what's interesting is you know we also
can take a step back and say like what's
the landscape of health information that
created this
opportunity for a kid in his 20s by the
way no one knows his last name very
clever no one knows his last name um
i'll play derek he's kind of an avatar
of a human right although he's real um
what created this landscape for this guy
to be able to get this information out
there even though he's not a physician
he's not a scientist and i think what it
is is that he saw that there was all
this information nested in these very
niche communities that most people don't
want to look like a bodybuilder right
and yet what he did was he sort of
normalized the discussion about hormones
he normalized the discussion about other
things like dopamine and cortisol etc
and what's interesting is that science
now
is kind of following suit you know 10
years ago a discussion about hormone
therapies would never come up in the
hallways of discussions with my
colleagues since doing
an episode of the podcast on optimizing
testosterone and estrogen no fewer than
10 of i'm not going to name names but
these are serious scientists and it's a
mixture of men and women have approached
me about like hey like what can one do
in order to adjust testosterone or
estrogen levels is
um estrogen therapy for menopause a
useful thing when should one start now
i'm not an endocrinologist so all i can
do is point them in the way of
information but this is an important
area and here's why
hormones control neuromodulators like
dopamine estrogen and so on and those
neuromodulators powerfully influence our
states of mind so if your hormones are
out of whack your neuromodulator is
going to be out of whack typically the
treatment for depression would be to go
in and just
give a serotonin reuptake inhibitor or
wellbutrin type dopamine thing and that
has its use but i love this
trend now not towards hormone therapy
necessarily but just toward a thinking a
mindset of how deep in the layers of my
biology can i go to create these sort of
waves of health that rise up to the
level of
ability to focus
and etc for so many years it's all been
attacked at the surface kind of the
waves
on the surface of the ocean and yet
there's this like we're now talking
about the deep tectonic plates movements
that are affecting all that in any case
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you